I'll be going rich buddies pre-owned Pat
welcome back to some more condom man
avatar today any questions
but it's alright you give me back my
give me back my toilet that one [ __ ]
toilet seat sorry all right hey it's
clear guys it's clear
don't worry but what are you doing boy
that is fine toilet lid I'll take it
slow like I take your mama oh okay
how do I crowd hey don't throw toilet
then give me back boat okay I just go
there
Oh No Jory you doing you got a taste of
toilet lead
hello that was so loud that's a cry oh
[ __ ]
it's okay I'm ready ready I'm glad you
are totally led I'm glad you I we should
go and have dinner sometime it sounded
sorry toilet lid I'm a bit what do you
know don't shoot me done showed me how
many toilet lid is it where do you got
let's [ __ ] did he got sugar on the poker
what are you doing ah give me a [ __ ]
heart attack
[ __ ] you I haven't turned in late okay
don't swear in toilets is present you
make toilet lid cry man all right but
bedpost up being an attention [ __ ] all
right why the [ __ ] are we going come on
what the [ __ ] all right it's over here
hey man what the [ __ ] what's up with
that scaring me
was it divide the top lick it neck at
[ __ ] alright again we're so [ __ ]
good
that's a nice all right [ __ ] with me I
don't like washing in here
no yes I was just about to say that
okay I'm scrubbing out other weapons yes
well you have to think outside the box
all right
are there any trains do are there any
trains operating oh that is just turned
up nothing conclusive we're going to
check out the rest of this wing excuse
me are you questioning the man that has
a toilet lid [ __ ] off all right I'm
going with a [ __ ] that's scared yeah
this guy's a genius sending the guy with
the toilet lid first I bring it
right Claire oh my god I'm so I stole
your de mer
[ __ ] yeah had a syringe in his hand
okay can I look at my handsomeness and
without having liquid [ __ ] coming
and [ __ ] with me that's a good scare
that good scare right there shakers all
right it's got a [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh no oh hello I can't even thank you
eat my lid in it taste it drink it
blockage [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah brofist
your ass but stay down stay down you
don't break my [ __ ] toilet leg you
piece of [ __ ] I kill it for this [ __ ]
kill you for this
a son of a [ __ ] I can't believe you did
that
toilet Lily yes sir
alright okay I'm sorry tell me when
you're done hey what are you doing [ __ ]
out its others Presley all right what
are we no no
what's going on here why did you go down
yeah I saw him where I a man you know no
Rufus block issue punch it
night dip down right nipple what are you
I can't see you
[ __ ] I shed this not good
rubbish your face professor nipple get
him but it's so ugly maybe if you like
more Oh
combo match it's so difficult to kill
them without a weapon like this are not
come on up it sucks to be a it's so dark
holy [ __ ] alright maybe this through
this door okay call it's got to be over
here right
the light is telling me to go ahead it
says exit some of course is locked
fantastic how many we've been in here
come on light switch it's clearly not on
my side shut this is difficult
alright don't worry baby we're fine
why are fine I told her to know where
we're going it's not difficult to orient
or anything okay this is where we came
from how the [ __ ] will I get back exit
doesn't worry what do you want mad a tap
should I shake those TVs out is there
something important in those I kind of
feel like there never is anything oh I
don't know alright what's going on here
we come back together man
I miss you Peter you kill me I'm sorry
about that man I saw that it sucks it
sucks when that happens to you alright
I guess we gotta keep going man I just
don't know where I shot a map or some
[ __ ] like that maybe I do I wouldn't
even know no I can't even go through
that what why why ever gene okay here it
is finally I know why that was so
difficult
how's it going dude planning I'm doing
taking a shortcut now step back got in a
teabag anger Manish man you're so
[ __ ] ugly it's wrong with your face
where do they go okay alright I'm coming
with ya all right I did it
what oh [ __ ] I broke my penis what the
[ __ ] just happened
I'm fine don't worry about me
where's my toilet lid I [ __ ] we don't
have it anymore
[Applause]
[ __ ] what are you doing
I meant no running in the hallways Oh No
hey hey hey hey hey hey no yes no no no
no stop stop stop stop
duck stop your stop stop dad said this
is oh it's a dance-off oh look at this
move
Oh check him out hit it oh okay okay you
win you win you win
I'm outta here mother it's a dumb idea
dum i de spectrum hecho not now
I need a weapon am I gonna beat you give
me a weapon why are you so all right
brofist I'm seriously I'm gonna beat
that guy with these please tell me where
is this a point their fists weapon give
me a fist weapon then where is he he was
here he's right I got that's fine then
fine then I go without him oh wait this
was where the elevator [ __ ] Oh bedpost I
guess it's better than [ __ ] nothing
and then you go through here and then
he's here yeah
[ __ ] hey man I really like your nipples
I admire them I didn't think so
I think so it's not all your gut is that
really all you got though is that really
all you got - these are really [ __ ]
all you got I broke this your [ __ ]
mama's face I'm sorry that was rude I'm
sorry I was out of line sorry about that
sorry I'm dying I'm sorry about that I
shouldn't have made that joke
hi what is this okay
your Spangler can detect all right let's
do some science stuff all right gimme
[ __ ] give me something ah there we go
why is he coming what is up with that
plane
okay but well oh there it is
how do I punch it shut up shut up shut
up okay I found it now what do I [ __ ] do
I do
okay let's throw you at it it didn't
work dinner [ __ ] ah there we go
alright that's how you roll or fine
[Applause]
[Music]
what's your problem I have a bed if you
try to dance in front of me I'm the
dance master have you seen my just
answer my Oreos oh can you clearly have
them otherwise you wouldn't have been
doing this you would regret this I punch
your [ __ ] stay down stay down
job on netball tres oh wait oh say my
name say my name say my name that's you
couldn't say my name I couldn't do it
that's understandable what is this a
brick alright now I don't see why not
alright we got to get somewhere I guess
I got to go back here they were here
maybe nope close the door no we're going
in there don't be silly
saving contents that means I got
anything but like a beverage you enjoy
subscribe to come to bridge today and
I'll see you next episode why have I
make this game is supposed to be a lot
scarier once you get more into it but I
order to think it's pretty scary so it's
kind of interesting say ah summer
looking at your fly's open it's close it
stopped da-da-da-dah me stop looking at
me
[ __ ] you